and I think we're lying
I think we're alive when I live from
well and alive oh wait this is this is
unlisted okay now we should be public
all right oh that's a that's a new
record for us I know it usually takes
forever public so fast and no I get some
people in here now we don't need
anyone's eyes in here don't need anyone
all by ourselves
you got one person though what what
who's the first one person in his first
chat person to see the new set on
YouTube live two people this is going
one this is coming this is it if it
didn't go poorly we wouldn't be who we
are we always it's always a gamble we
always gotta grab something make it
because the stream stream is bad hey we
got some people chatting what's up guys
how you guys do it don't worry hoist
nurse stream is picking up some some
energy here yeah new set new set new
look we'll talk about this sonic trailer
in a second vibe hi hi hi you guys can
hear us right that's always the
confirmation we need to hear you guys
can hear us right Conard four-week
killing the game with the commons hmm
portugal all right cool all right we got
a hundred 21 people in here all right
let's just hop right into this then
shall we yeah man the Sonic the Hedgehog
movie we've seen it it's mass is he's so
much better than detected Pikachu we saw
with the original design they shouldn't
changed it this video was sponsored by
Paramount and I wanna say wait you guys
okay no Kiki is some guy was just like
all right okay so make sure to have as
many endgame
[Laughter]
yeah so we have officially moved out of
the apartment now we got a new set you
guys can barely see it right now we got
a new step we are going to be going into
this talk in a minute but yeah we still
got some other videos that we shot in
April that we got to upload through the
weekend but we thought we'd just touch
base with you guys since this is the
first room taken care of now the whole
weekend's gonna be dedicated to
unpacking the rest so we can get ready
for Game of Thrones and have a living
room to shoot in him by the time your
Thrones rolls around
vot um but yeah we spent all day on this
room unpacking settling everything in
but yeah maybe in that with a clearer
camera when it's not a live stream
camera we'll be able to see the shot any
hope let's get into this shall we
so with the Sonic the Hedgehog design I
haven't seen any I know there's a lot of
youtubers who are making videos and I've
actually been a little bit away from
YouTube for the most part in the past
two to three moving stuff and unpacking
things and building the set yeah yeah
but would this announcement use that's
Sonic the Hedgehog I like how this guy
said your house sucks oh yeah I think
you can't even see it yeah we're gonna
move because you said so basically this
this announcement that the director said
on Twitter you know basically what he
was said was that we hurt we appreciate
the support of the criticism port as
well as the criticism and we hear you
loud and clear and we're gonna get a new
yeah we are happy with the design you
want changes needs he has type like fix
it fast or something we will be reading
your guys's comments here do you guys
actually think this is gonna fix
anything honestly do you guys actually
think it'll do something great because
I'm under the impression that this movie
is like my my feelings when we saw the
trailer if you watch our reaction we're
both the least thing we talked about was
actually the design like sure I get if
you're a hardcore Sonic fan how that
design can upset you simultaneous
though my that was like one of them that
was maybe a major problem for the
hardcore Sonic fans but just as a person
watching this movie trailer it just
looked really bad so I'm like are you
gonna fixing the design does not fix the
movie in some ways actually when I was
laying down before we went live was how
if you it's kind of like Ally to battle
angel where then the trailers Aleta
looked weird and it wasn't as much of a
backlash but if she looked weird in the
trailer so then you watch the movie the
context of the movie is fine so you can
forget the design here and like you you
could have gotten away with design if
the movie was actually if the movies
actually good and then somehow within
the context of the film the design is
fine but but to go and just fix the
design it's not gonna really fix the
movie granted I know we're already
predetermined this is gonna be a bad
movie but there's all these rest at this
point I'd be surprised if it's a good
movie at this point I mean yeah just
because of their willingness to just
jump right in and be like we're gonna
change it and the thing is yeah I was
kind of there with you I didn't love the
design and I play sonic growing up so I
was sitting there during the trailer
going this looks kind of creepy but if
the movies good around it yeah like I
can forgive it I can probably get used
to it having said that I've seen a few
of the fan rendered updates that I very
much prefer to what the movie is trying
to offer us by making him look like
splitting the difference between a
something real and a cartoon character
yeah the proportions make him look weird
but yeah ultimately I don't think that
the the biggest problem we had with the
trailer was that it looked like a weird
flat like 90s bargain bin comedy sci-fi
thing and and yeah I don't know like
updating the design is I think a move
that's probably smart because if they
can pull it off they'll probably at
least get the sonic fans who are like
well maybe it doesn't cut a good trailer
but at least it looks like Sonic you
know like I can see I don't know what
the risk reward is for the investment in
spending all that money to redo all your
effects and whatnot but maybe they think
it'll equate to ticket sales it's like
what it's like what this guy right here
saying I won't fix the story or
performances it will
these fans on a visual level but we
don't it's to me it's it's gonna be the
reaction of we're probably gonna get a
second trailer Sonic's gonna look better
we're all people will probably be like
oh now this looks like a good movie oh
but that I feel like it's just gonna be
a trickery of the mind at that point the
fact that that is the fact that it looks
like an improvement will not mean that
it's a good movie at that point but
people are easily usually can be pretty
fooled by things like that you know yeah
I'm really curious because yeah my
outset I don't feel like this is gonna
be a good movie but I also don't want to
treat it as though it's a bad movie
because I don't know
and and so yeah I feel like this will
get least give them a chance to come
back with the second trailer and make a
different impression because I think too
if they've paid attention to the
backlash to design and they've probably
paid attention at least who would agree
to how people feel about the actual
content of the trailers so yeah I mean
they could just go for a different tone
of the next trailer to trick us in
because they also I don't know like they
said they're aiming for families with
this and the first trailer feels like a
kids movie trailer to me and I feel like
even though there is a kid appeal to
Sonic and Sonic has often existed in a
kid-friendly environment I feel like the
market for a sonic bad dog movie is
people who were kids when Sonic the
Hedgehog was at his height so I wonder
where the movie is going to go in that
respect because I think an actual kids
movie Sonic would probably not please a
lot of people definitely well I feel
sorry for the animators like Wheaton I
mean I didn't really I didn't interview
with that makeup artist Jill Harlow who
worked with many of films and he didn't
make this little comment but it's very
you didn't even go into depth about it
but hearing what a lot of like visual
effects artists animators have said you
know usually they people will usually
hire YouTube you know like two for a
cheap rate they're like who's the
cheapest one we can get and they're not
probably gonna pay these animators more
money to work their asses off on this
project and just right now this is just
feeling more like it always felt like a
more
heating gimmick to me that always felt
like a just a commercial film it's the
song of the Hedgehog but we always felt
that way but now more than ever it's
feeling a lot more like that and I'm
also thinking about you know how when
Avengers endgame before we even saw
Thanos we saw a toy of Thanos they
probably already had toys in the
pipeline ready to go you know and now
that they don't I'm thinking about well
what are you gonna take I feel like they
could always just lose more money by
doing this I did trailer for the fact
that the trailer itself on Paramount
Pictures has like 200,000 more dislikes
than likes it's more than just the
design it's it's the movie in itself it
has to be both yeah of course it's both
but it I think there definitely is a
percentage of people who go I hate the
sonic design and I dislike this video
like I do think that the both play
strong factor in it yeah you know I feel
like it would have gotten more likes had
have been a good trailer but it still
would have gotten a good percentage of
dislikes had it been a decent trailer
with a bad sonic so the guy says
everyone in this chat what do you guys
think of what do you guys think of Jim
Carrey in this trailer
cuz weirdly I mean for me I I I've grown
up a huge Jim Carrey fan as of late I'm
more drawn to his dramatic work than I
am as comedy work as his comedy work
always feels like he's trying to channel
young Jim Carrey but it doesn't feel
like what he actually wants to do well
curious to know what do you guys think
of Jim Carrey in this trailer because I
feel like I've been hearing a lot of
people actually saying he's the best
part of this trailer so we got a yes-no
for dr. abundant yes okay what no Jim
were paying attention who should have
been in a fat suit hey yeah it's true
yeah it was a good look okay okay yeah I
mean you see this maybe it looks like
funny enough the last shot of Jim Carrey
the design of him there seems to satisfy
fans well yeah because that's the design
of doctor yeah that's when he looks like
the character because I don't know I
mean maybe there's one or a few games
that I haven't played where he has that
more like
normal guy like just mustachioed look
but yeah the dr. Robotnik I know is like
goggles and [ __ ] crazy ass mustache
and he's always like scheming and stuff
uh-huh and yeah so like - it's weird
because yeah in that last shot you're
like this is all that this movie could
be yeah and then you wonder yeah is this
gonna be like inter Tomb Raider where
this is like the last shot or something
setting up for a sequel because that's a
world that exists I think in the Sonic
universe with the giant mushrooms and
stuff and I'm sitting there going that's
the movie like right let's get some
fantasy in here and Jim Carrey is
perfect for that level of dr. Robotnik
and so yeah this is all very weird I
mean it is based off that based off what
I've heard from other people's videos
and a stuff just asking people in the
chat what they think it seems like most
people are not everyone but most people
are on board okay it's the overall
reaction I think that Jim Carrey has
been he's gonna be the best part of this
movie but he won't save the movie he's
do you know what I mean hey yeah yeah
yeah he sees the most reliable element
you know that people like and that
usually even when not fully inspired you
know at least brings a certain charm you
know yes because I feel bad for James
Marsden because like I like him a lot
and and a lot of people don't really
care that much specifically about him so
if this movie looks like monster trucks
is exactly like a monster same kind of
vibe where I'm sitting here going this
could be surprisingly fun in a throwback
II kind of way or this could just be a
train ride I guess I can't tell if it
feels intentional or not in the
throwback II kind of way cuz it feels
like a bad 90s video game adaptation but
it could work if it's intentional yeah
you know if that is the intent to kind
of do a fun spin or play on that it
could definitely work to its advantage
you know Dennis Hopper played Bowser but
hey we mean there's gonna be a very
short live stream guys but okay wait a
minute
oh yeah the teeth are weird yeah I mean
I think the design does look weird yeah
you should look like an actual hedgehog
yeah
a completely different purport it walks
on four legs not I think they should
double down for size so really all right
they had issues we're gonna make it even
more real he's brown now he doesn't even
collect rings or fighting like evil
doctors gosh
I guarantee guys I mean for everyone
who's like asking about knuckles and
Tails and all that they'll be in the
pellet suit oh yeah they'll allude to
them somewhere the whole thing about
like a sonic happiness saved the human
world and team up with the human we
didn't I didn't need that transformers
thing you know what was cool about
bumblebee which is funny because this
looks like this looks like it dumble B
meets monster trucks right which monster
trucks in a lot of ways was a bad
version of um but you know what the best
part one of the things for fans that
they really love that bumblebee was just
starting off in Cybertron mmm and being
in that world there and you could have
done that with Sonic just put them in
Sonic world yeah you know what I've
heard other people cite the Smurfs movie
is like the first one it's like The
Smurfs are in human world and I think
most of us in the second movie they went
to you know the Smurfs world and that
went over better you know alright well
look guys we're gonna head it on this we
just wanted to check in with you guys
real fast let you know that we will be
back uploaded regularly by Sunday no no
I mean we got videos that we have to
upload over the course Sunday but Monday
new Game of Thrones episode so we got to
get the living room ready for that yeah
ended on this good news for video game
movies detective Pikachu is certified
fresh' right now on Rotten Tomatoes and
it's got a good amount of reviews so it
seems like the general consensus is yeah
and it also there's even some negative
reviews that I've read just the capsules
that are like if you're not if you don't
know who like Jigglypuff is or all that
then you probably won't like this and
I'm like I know who I probably get a
like you know so detective Pikachu might
be the first great video game movie but
hey thank you guys for checking in with
us we're gonna shoot a reaction for
Supernatural for a patreon page John has
started
during Cobra Kai season to honor patreon
as well
because of all that conundrum mayhem
that happen with the Wayne trailer
that's why we're doing that just for our
patreon page also um really quick last
thing I'll ask last thing I'll ask for
the few people who are still here what
do you think of the voice work of sonic
goddess wait silently god I'd like a mr.
Roger show like the Mister Rogers show
yeah people like alright so people are
fine with that all right cool I didn't
know if people were like I hate this
actor but it seems like for the most
part it'll be fine you know no one i
watch back a few of the cartoons and i
was like okay you know this seems in the
spirit all right well guys we'll catch
you guys soon
and who knows maybe we'll do more live
streams and have a little bit of a prep
to it next time yeah
see you guys